Come here. Come here.
My webcam doesn't even work.
You know what these are?
What are they? Nuts.
You don't know what these are? Hazelnuts?
These are hazelnuts. No!
That's not what it is. They're kinda weird.
What are these one?
Those are cashews. I hate cashew nuts.
I hate hazelnuts.
Do you like chocolate-covered honey comb? No.
Yes, actually. Oh, you do?
Take some of these. Alright.
Speaking of mixed nuts,
today we've got a whole mix of
a bunch of weird stuff.
It's not a typical episode. We're just full of
facts and bunch of people
I met over here in London. So,
enjoy.
I learned something.
Your eyeballs
grow when you're a kid.
Sh*t. Yeah.
But once you turn 13 years old your eyeballs -
they stop growing. But you know what?
Your ears keep growing for ever.
Did you know that?
Did you drink for breakfast again?
No, no, no, no.
But apparently, like every adult's
eyeballs are like the exact same size within
a couple millimetres.
Yeah.
So your eyes are the same size as my,
it's just your face is different. Like shows them off better. My face is better than your face.
Well, that we already established. But I'm
trying to talk about the anatomy of the eye.
Thanks for ruining my self-esteem instead.
Anytime.
Okay, here's a fact that'll make you feel happy.
Did you know
that in a deck of cards there are so many ways to
arrange those cards
that when you shuffle a deck,
the order of those cards
has never ever existed on Earth
in history.
Yeah.
So whenever you feel sad, shuffle a deck.
Set aside and say "first."
Three hundred and
fifty. The idea was not really great in this
weight-lifting room,
but I need to be here because I ate a
bunch of liquid nitrogen
ice cream a couple days ago. It's this
place where they take liquid cream and
sugar and all the ingredients
and rather than spend a bunch of time
waiting for it to cool down,
they fill up a big ol' jug with liquid nitrogen
that freezes the cream in a matter of
seconds into delicious ice cream.
They even serve the toppings out of
beakers and test tubes,
and it was delicious. After eating the
ice cream we stumbled upon an electric
harp player
and she told me after the show that even
though the harp's electric, the strings
are still made the traditional way -
out of the intestines of animals.
Of course, you have to admit that the
only thing more delicious than liquid
nitrogen
ice cream or animal intestines is a cake
in the face
by iJustine.
I leave you with British Pathé.
These guys have been filming human
activities
since we could film human activities and
they're putting all that content
out on the YouTube for free right now.
They've got early Arnold,
they've got chickens being
hatched in a frying pan
and old taxidermy museum
and, of course, dogs getting married.
Would you subscribe to British Pathé?
[Hazel:] I think so.
[Michael:] Yeah. Of course. As should all of you.
Subscribe to Vsauce if you haven't.
[Hazel:] Oh my god, you're checking me again!
And as always,
thanks for watching.